E
STATE DEPARTMENT AND THE CIA.
NATIONAL SECURITY CORRESPONDENT
JENNIFER GRIFFIN HAS THE LATEST
TONIGHT FROM THE PENTAGON.
>> I WON'T COMMENT WHAT'S IN THE
BOOK.
I HAVE CONFIDENCE IN GENERAL
MILLEY.
>> PENTAGON OFFICIALS SAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ACTING DEFENSE
SECRETARY CHRIS MILLER SHOULD
HAVE BEEN AWARE OF THE CALL THAT
GENERAL MILLEY HAD WITH HIS
CHINESE COUNTERPART IN JANUARY
BECAUSE HIS OWN DEPUTY FOR CHINA
POLICY HELD A SIMILAR CALL WITH
HIS CHINESE COUNTERPART TWO DAYS
BEFORE GENERAL MILLEY'S VIDEO
TELECONFERENCE CALL AND RECORDS
SHOW GENERAL MILLEY'S CALL WAS
COORDINATED WITH THE OFFICE OF
THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE.
ON JANUARY 1st, TALKING POINTS
FOR THE CALL WERE SHARED WITH
OSD.
ON JANUARY 4TH.
OSD COORDINATED THE CALL.
ON JANUARY 6TH, A MEMBER OF
MILLER'S OWN STAFF SPOKE WITH
COUNTERPART.
TWO DAYS LATER GENERAL MILLEY
SPOKE TO GENERAL LI.
FOX HAS LEARNED THE JANUARY 6TH
CALL WAS INITIATED BY THE
CHINESE EVEN THOUGH PREPARATIONS
HAD BEEN IN THE WORKS FOR SOME
TIME.
AFTER TELLING FOX NEWS THAT HE
WAS NOT AWARE AND DID NOT
AUTHORIZE GENERAL MILLEY'S
JANUARY CALL, ACTING DEFENSE
SECRETARY MILLER HAS WALKED BACK
HIS STATEMENT.
HE NOW TELLS POLITICO, QUOTE:
LOOKING BACK I IMAGINE THERE WAS
A PER FUNG TORE EXCHANGE BETWEEN
US AND OUR STAFFS ABOUT
COORDINATING PHONE CALLS AND
MESSAGES FOR THE DAY.
IN OCTOBER THEN DEFENSE
SECRETARIES MARK HE IS OFFICER
ORDERED HIS TEAM AHEAD OF
GENERAL MILLEY'S CALL TO LOWER
THE TEMPERATURE.
FOX NEWS HAS LEARNED IT WAS
DURING THE OCTOBER PHONE CALL
THAT ASSURANCES WERE GIVEN TO
THE CHINESE LEADER THAT THE U.S.
HAD NO PLANS FOR A SURPRISE
MILITARY STRIKE, AN EFFORT TO
CALM TEXAS.
>> THIS SEEMS TO ME ON THE
SURFACE OF IT TO BE RESPONSIBLE
ACTS BEING TAKEN BY SECRETARY HE
IS OFFICER AND ALSO BY GENERAL
MILLE.
MILLEY NEEDS TO COME FORWARD.
FORMER SECRETARY ESPER NEEDS TO
COME FORWARD AND LET THEM TELL
THE STORY.
THE SOONER THEY DO THAT THE
BETTER TO CLEAR UP THIS MESS
THAT'S OUT THERE HIS AIDES SAY
THAT'S THE APPROPRIATE VENUE TO
ADDRESS THESE QUESTIONS NOT
THROUGH THE MEDIA.
FOX HAS ALSO LEARNED THERE WAS
NEVER A BAN ON CALLS OR CONTACT
WITH THE CHINESE BY THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THAT, ACCORDING TO SENIOR NSC